fantastic great thanks Jeffy for that
introduction it's great to be back at
Berkeley and get to talk a little bit
about some of the work that's going on
and so I'm gonna talk today about safety
critical autonomous systems and say a
little bit about that and I'm at Caltech
but also visiting assignments Institute
is the Simon Institute for the theory of
computing or of the theory of computing
Dec should tell us is it for the theory
alright fantastic I've got all right
okay good I didn't have to do any
real-time changes to my slides okay so
what are the types of systems that I
want to talk about today well these are
systems that we all trust and believe
we'll sort of perform correctly and if
they don't bad things happen so for
example aircraft r1 so I flew in this
morning on Southwest so I thought I'd
give him a heads up and if we can turn
the white watch with lights off that
would probably be useful just so we can
see things a little better um and of
course we fly on these systems every day
and we trust that when we get on a plane
we're gonna get to where we go and that
nothing Bad's gonna happen and that
works right and so it's certainly a
safety-critical control system when
these things go bad something bad
happens of course you know for many of
us especially here in the San Francisco
area another upcoming safety critical
control system are autonomous cars and
so these are running around right now
with usually with safety drivers right
but eventually people are talking about
they're gonna run around without safety
drivers and so we need to think about
you know how are they gonna work and
what's going to happen etc and so I'll
talk a little bit of that thanks Claire
so I put up here one from new tana me
because I have no affiliation with new
autonomy but three of my students work
there so I figure they may be doing
something that relates to things that
I'm doing even though they won't tell me
about it
but there are lots of other types of
safety critical control systems but for
example to some extent the power grid is
a safety critical system just in the
sense that if it were to go down and go
down at the wrong time and go down for
too long right this would cause major
problems I think here we changed the
lights just so we could see the slides a
little bit better see me all right you
want change them okay so they'll reset
those so this is another one and one of
the things that you know all of these
have in common is they are all examples
of safety critical real-time
decision-making systems the topic
our particular program that's going on
at the sinuses to that and that I'm part
of and so I want to talk a little bit
about these and for me part of the
motivation and those were you see me
speak before I've heard me talk some
about this was the DARPA Grand Challenge
that happened back in 2004 to 2007 which
Caltech participated in with a bunch of
undergraduates the Caltech
undergraduates built this vehicle they
built several this is Alice actually the
first vehicle is Bob this is Alice and
so Alice is an autonomous vehicle
originally built for off-road driving
although we also used it for urban
driving it was built by 75 Caltech
undergraduates from scratch in about a
year and a half and so it kind of shows
you what can be done back in the this
was sort of circa 2006 was probably when
this picture was taken it consists of
lots of sensing lots of computing lots
of communications all integrated
together lots of different programs
running in a very complicated setting um
and it is the precursor or one of the
precursors to what we see now today many
of the DARPA Grand Challenge veterans
and alumni are the people who are
sitting in the self-driving car
companies and getting all of these
things to work and kind of bringing that
experience with them so if you kind of
look inside Alice what you would see
would be a bunch of modules that are
running on computers each of these
little boxes don't worry if you can read
the words represent some function that's
being carried out either some type of
sensing or navigation or decision-making
or other things all connected together
all working all running across 30 cores
or so worth of computing and carrying
out all of these computations and this
is very similar to what the
architectures that you would see in
today's self-driving cars that are
driving around downtown San Francisco
and other places and so they all have a
very kind of a similar set up lots of
different computation running now on you
know much more advanced CPUs and other
things but you know still basically the
same ideas and I think what amazed me
back at the time that we're doing this
is that all of this can actually work
with actually know enough about how to
get these to run and so this is an
example of what Alice look like as it
was driving along so you're seeing it
driving in an intersection coming up to
an intersection waiting until it's its
turn so it has to sense those other
vehicles determine okay it's now its
turn to go it goes through the
intersection it doesn't know exactly
where things are so it has to localize
figure out where the lane lines are and
other things it has no prior map so this
is back before these thing
we're kind of mapped in exquisite detail
that was not part of the rules so you
see it kind of veering around a little
bit as it tries to figure out what's
going on
comes up to another intersection stops a
fair distance behind that's set by the
rules waits until it's it turned to go
as soon as that car goes through it says
great I can now pull up to the
intersection stop at the stop line so it
comes up the intersection it knows the
other car was there first waits until it
goes through and then it goes through
the intersection right so all of this is
running with nobody in the car right you
know having to figure out where all the
lane lines are where all the other cars
are sensing everything around it and
doing real-time decision-making about
you know how to make all of those things
happen and so in that particular spot
you saw it doing some relatively simple
maneuvers certainly all of us could do
that if we were driving a car but now of
course doing that all autonomously and
working more or less correctly right you
can prove the performance on other
things but you know basically did what
it was supposed to do um but it didn't
always do the right thing here's another
same time this is from the DARPA Grand
Challenge in 2007 where it's trying to
go through an intersection there's cars
coming both ways you can see it kind of
hesitates going forward it starts going
forward it stops it backs up in the
middle of the intersection and then
starts to make a turn very hesitantly
cars are coming up they're honking at us
hey you got all the way what are you
doing so we come in finally right you
know sort of get in the lane and start
driving right people freaked out a
little bit about you knows where we are
right you know they see a you know three
ton truck coming at them and they sort
of all I'm not sure I want to do that
right so what happened right that's
probably not very safe behavior right
and if there'd been pedestrians and
other things and that type of an error
it happened you can imagine somebody
might have gotten hurt and so was very
interesting is that what happened there
in fact if you kind of go over to the
diagram and say well something went
wrong there was a bug someplace in fact
the bug was that there were inconsistent
assumptions between two different layers
of abstraction right where a higher
layer thought one thing was going on and
a lower layer thought something else was
going on and they got inconsistent and
it got confused and I'll explain a
little bit more what those layers are
and what was going on but essentially we
missed it right we did lots of driving
these lots of testing we did lots of
simulations right but there was this one
condition that we'd never seen before
that somehow caused the system to get
confused and and of course in a safety
critical control system that's what
you're worried about that one condition
in a million right that's going to
happen and you got to simulate a lot
right in order to get that condition and
you may never
and so that was the type of thing we
were looking at and to me at that time
that really motivated thinking about
well how in the world are we gonna
design these sort of complex systems
animal work so how do we design systems
of this complexity how do we make sure
they function as their desire so let me
generalize that a little bit and just
talk about kind of safety critical
autonomous systems mainly autonomous
vehicles but as I said the power grid
and other things might be there and I
think one question we should ask is how
safe is safe I mean how safe do we need
things to be and so for example we can
look at what some of the statistics are
and safety in the current systems that
we have
so vehicles human driven vehicles the
safety record for human driven vehicles
is about 7 deaths for every billion
miles driven so that's about what a
human can do right now traffic deaths
due to an accident or something like
that either the people in the car or
people around the car um so that seems
maybe pretty safe all right
nobody here drives a billion miles right
so you hundred million miles right you
would kill less than one person but
there are a lot of miles driven alright
so in the United States that turns out
to be 35,000 traffic deaths per year
just in the US right because they're
that many miles driven and that's
certainly way too many right leading
cause of death in some sense you know up
there on the list of things that kill
people
so are there safer ways well you can
look at what happens in train and rail
types of systems so something like the
San Francisco metro as an example so
buses and trains turn out to be about 20
times safer so point 1 to point 4 deaths
per billion miles driven and so you know
really quite a lot safer than driving
yourself but the safest mode of
transportation maybe not too
surprisingly since is the one we hear
the least about people getting hurt in
is in fact air transportation and the
statistics there are 0.07 deaths per
billion miles it's a hundred times safer
for me to fly from Pasadena up to
Berkeley than it is for me to drive that
same distance I mean so if you have to
choose and you want to go down to LA
you're gonna come up to the San
Francisco you should fly if you're
worried about your safety
because it's a hundred times safer you
do that
and these statistics come from this
paper it's a little bit dated now but
kind of goes through all of those things
and this is in the United States so this
is a sort of US state so I think we can
ask you know a couple of things about
that so you know how is it that in the
aerospace system aerospace industry
we're able to make things so safe right
you know what's going on there right and
so you know I think there are a couple
of things so one is that they're very
strong certification requirement so you
can't just put software in an airplane
and try it out you actually have to go
through a certification process that
certification process there many of them
but one of them is called do-178c and
do-178c establishes how safe as an
engineer you have to guarantee your
software is or demonstrate that your
software is before you're allowed to put
it out in use by the public and there
are a variety of levels of safety and so
there's hazard classes and a what's the
software level for that and the number
of failures per flight hour catastrophic
failure means possible loss of human
life so that's the you know the software
does something in the plane might
actually crash and for for level a
software right where the failure of that
software could lead to a catastrophic
error what you have to demonstrate is
you will have no more than one failure
in every billion hours of operation
right so billion hours of operation
training will be a hundred thousand
years
all right so every hundred thousand
years your software is allowed to have a
bug that trip trips right so that's
pretty damn safe and but that's what you
have to demonstrate and so there are a
variety of processes for doing that and
so this do-178c has a lot of you know
how do you actually demonstrate that
what type of analysis do you have to do
all of those things so part of the
reason that aircraft systems are so safe
is that they're strong regulations
around those that force the engineers
designing them many of these were of
course things developed by the industry
right because you obviously want airline
safety to be something that the public
can trust and so that's kind of where
we've ended up on that but there are
other things of course that make the air
traffic system particularly safe for
example it's a very structured operating
environment you have air traffic control
and other things that are moving things
around you have very well-trained
personnel is it's a pilot right who gets
hours of training many hundreds of hours
of training probably every year in
addition to flying and getting certified
and all of those things and you have
very expensive vehicles right airplanes
are not cheap there may be on order a
million dollars per passenger all right
and so you can do a lot right and I'll
tell you some about what some of those
things are
um I think we now think about okay good
so it's possible to design these systems
that are that safe and we demonstrated
we can build them that safe how might we
do that in the automotive industry you
know can we get to that level of safety
so at the component level things are
actually pretty good your car components
don't break in a way that causes death
very often most deaths are caused right
due to the humans driving them right
making a mistake not you know due to
your engine going out of your tire going
out all right you're something going on
inside your car sometimes but not that
often um if you start thinking about
autonomous vehicles right now a lot of
the backup stuff right that happens when
you have a failure is the human right oh
my tire went out I need to pull over to
the side of the road right oh my engine
stall ready need to figure out a safe
path all of those things so as we start
doing that in autonomous vehicles that
the vehicle level we're gonna have to be
a little bit more fault tolerant right
most of the autonomous cars that are out
there driving right now are designed to
drive when all four wheels are inflated
and the engines running and the brakes
are working and the transmissions
working and the communication systems
are working and the networks are working
and the computers are working right and
all of that stuff and so we're gonna
have to say okay what if that's not all
the case right your aircraft can run on
one engine actually run on zero engines
rank for a little while and so you know
they've thought about how do you run in
Fault conditions right not how do you
just sort of say okay it's a fault
condition I give up you know everybody's
dead right and or it's a fault condition
pilot figure it out right the aircraft
can actually still continue to operate
and of course I think the hardest thing
that we're gonna see in in automotive
systems is that the the system level
right so when you're around people and
it's in a mixed environment and all of
that stuff is going on right and so
that's going to be the really hard
problem where I think we have very hard
challenges okay so these are the types
of things that I've been thinking about
you know for the last couple of years in
some sense motivated by the DARPA Grand
Challenge but increasingly for me it's
been more on the aerospace side that
we've applied some of the ideas that I'm
going to tell you about so what I want
to tell you about today is a little bit
of that so I'm gonna start by telling
you more about the aerospace systems and
how are things down there and what are
some of the challenges even in aerospace
systems that we're working on and I'll
say a little bit not know particularly
deep but try and give you a little bit
of a sense about some of the ideas
mathematically and in control theory
which is my field you know and how do
you do that right what are the tools we
can apply what are the various
techniques and it's a very nice
combination of ideas that are coming
from computer science and controls and
many other just
and then at the end of the talk I'll try
and kind of come back to self-driving
cars and talk a little bit about you
know can these be applied should they be
applied how might they be applied what
does that look like because this is an
area that's changing very rapidly right
so since 2007 right you know they've
been dozens of companies that have come
out that are now building these cars and
I just like to point out that a lot of
the work I'm going to talk about today
is in fact tied to things going on here
at Berkeley and in particular a lot of
the aerospace stuff is stuff that we did
as part of the IEEE sci-fi project that
was done with Edward Lee and Alberto San
Giovanni - them to telly and a lot of
the self-driving car work his stuff that
we just started in the last year or so
Hasaan jet and Clara Andrew Shanker
Sastry tom griffith symbiont hartmann
here at berkeley and so this is very
much joint work with many people around
ok so let me start I'll say a little bit
about aerospace systems and try and give
you some insights there about that
industry and then say a little bit about
kind of the mathematics and control
theory behind this and then come back to
the self-driving kids ok so how do we
design complex aerospace systems and we
use a model-based development process
that's what the kind of current industry
standard is so that's MBD and
traditionally in an aerospace system
you'd have a design view right so you
would sort of start and say okay well I
want to start at the system level I'm
going to design the aircraft how big
should the wings be what should the
range B etc and then I'm gonna take this
down to the subsystem level I've got an
electric power subsystem a propulsion
subsystem hydraulic subsystem and then
I'm gonna eventually go down to the
component level I've got gears and
valves and transformers and other things
and so I'm gonna flow everything down
and then I'm gonna put it all back
together and verify it as I go back up
right so I gonna take all my specs at
the system level those gonna translate
to specs that the subsystem level those
are gonna translate to specs at the
component level I'm going to design the
components are going to put them
together when a test to make sure the
components satisfy their specs put them
back together make sure the subsystem
satisfies the spec put it together make
sure that the system satisfies the specs
and that has worked very well in the
aerospace industry for a long time and
was sort of developed when things were
relatively simple and so for example for
the electric power system for an
aircraft which is one of this about this
is a typical electric power system for
say 737 era aircraft I think this is
actually maybe a 757 era aircraft where
you have a an electric power system
there are generators on the engines that
are generating electrical power those
are powering up buses that are the loads
are connected to the loads are
right the various flight control
computers the various actuators and
other things and so you have maybe a
couple of different buses so the blue
things in the middle there are AC buses
you might have some transformer units
that transform those to lower power or
or DC depending on what you're doing
then you've got you know two engines a
backup generator on each engine just a
backup generator just in case the
primary generator fails maybe some
battery backup an auxilary power unit
right some redundancy built in there and
it's relatively easy to make sure that
this system right we'll have operate and
false if one engine goes out you'll
still have electrical power right you've
got a similar problem with propulsion
right do I have enough propulsion to you
know take off and land and other things
but just on the electrical power side
you have to worry about that too um it
gets more complicated when you try and
get more efficient the problem with this
system is that you're basically carrying
around two to three times the amount of
power generation capability that you
need to make sure that it's always there
right and as you start looking at and
try and optimize and get your airplane
to be more fuel efficient that means
lighter weight right and get it you know
to sort of be lower cost that means less
components the sooner you start saying
things like well do I really need a left
backup generator and a right backup
generator right and do I need each one
of those to be able to power up the
entire aircraft for example right maybe
I can say look they're four or five or
six the battery let's say there's a
battery backup an APU left two
generators right two generators can't I
assume that three of the six of those
are running and make sure that no matter
which of the three of the six of those
are running they have enough power right
and if that happens right that you know
the feel like Lee hood that three of
them fail is less than one in ten of the
nine five hours right I ought to be able
to get away with that but now the
problem is that it depends which three
right and how things are connected up
and so I start having to worry about how
do I route power in more sophisticated
ways because I don't know what's going
to be up and down and so you get a more
complex system to do that so this is
what the power electric power system
looks like for something like the 787
aircraft you remember may remember when
the 787 was coming out they had some
problems with the electric power system
you probably heard about in terms of
lithium batteries right and other things
that's what that system looks roughly
like um those little kind of oval like
things are the buses there are now a lot
more buses that were maybe
busses on the system when I was looking
at before right no no it's one two three
four five six seven eight nine and it
was probably a half dozen or a dozen
buses on this system lots of different
redundant paths they see lots of arrows
connecting these why because we need to
be able to route power no matter what
happens so these systems have gotten
more complexes we've tried to made them
higher performance lower cost higher
availability lower weight right all of
these sort of design challenges and this
is very much a software controlled
system because now all of the contactors
to say we're out power this way are all
controlled by a microprocessor some
place that's saying oh alright this
engine just went out so now I need to
reconnect the power and reflow it in
order to make sure that the right stuff
gets the right power and so the
challenge with these complex systems in
the aerospace industry what are they
struggling with they can build systems
that are that as safe as they are but it
is very expensive to do so and part of
the reason it's very expensive is that
you discover changes downstream so this
is a plot of the number of design
changes requested as a function of time
so on the horizontal axis you're looking
at the amount of time going by and then
on the vertical axis you're looking at
the number of change requests coming
through and what you see is that early
in the design process they're not very
many change requests but late in the
design process like when you're testing
things there are a lot of change
requests coming through so they're
discovering the problems with their
design late in the design stage and
that's very expensive right because now
you've already built the thing you've
already sized all the components you've
already Donald you're part way back up
that V right and so it's getting very
complicated right to change things and
go back and do everything so that's the
challenge in the aerospace industries
these things are too expensive right and
time-consuming and they get delivered
late you hear this right with all of the
aircraft that come out right that it's
you know we're over budget over time
right this is cutting into the
businesses Center and so in the
aerospace industry people who've thought
about well how do we do better and one
of the ways we can maybe do better is to
use models in a better way and to try
and do more up front so take this design
view and instead of waiting until we're
going back up the sort of design view to
discover problems try and do more on the
front end do little verification loops
let's make sure that everything works
let's have tighter specifications and
other things let's use formal methods
and others ideas that we'll talk about
earlier in that design process and can
we by doing that sort of thing shift
this curve so that maybe we get the same
number of change requests maybe we sort
of take that as a constant right
we're doing the design we're gonna you
know get things wrong but can we shift
it so those change requests the area is
the same but they come earlier in the
design phase when it's cheaper and so
this is where the aerospace industry is
going it's how do we pull up right those
changes so we can discover them earlier
when we're still doing stuff on paper
ideally right or in simulation right or
in you know very early prototyping rigs
rather than on a full aircraft and so
that's kind of where things are going
and you know the difficulty is this is
hard and there's more research needed to
figure out how to do that and so there's
a lot of things that people are trying
to figure out how to do verification of
these sorts of things cetera and I'll
talk more about these but model-based
synthesis is one of the things people
are doing so we need to design with
downstream verification in mind we need
to think about going from a design then
verify sort of a mentality to more of us
specify than synthesize type of
mentality and I'll talk more about that
in a second
now just to sort of you know show how
some of these things all play out I kind
of give you an example so when you look
at a modern aircraft you know it's got a
lot of subsystems so if you sort of peel
away the skin not only do you see the
seats everything else but there's wiring
running all over there's hydraulic pumps
all over the place and there's an you
know sort of cables and everything else
and we've got these kind of kind of
tight design specifications and it's
already mentioned for the catastrophic
failure so for anything software
controlled where the software going bad
could lead to loss of life we have a
hundred thousand years that we have to
demonstrate and just in the u.s. there's
about 30,000 flights a day turns out to
be on order 10 to the 8th flight hours
per year and so if you kind of look at
the world you know there ought to be
maybe you know one every year or two
software problems that lead to planes
crashing and that's about what happens
right every year or two you hear about
you know that Air France flying right or
that air Malaysia flight or whatever
right that sort of went down and we
don't know quite why and it might have
been part of the software right so
that's kind of the the level that we're
at so we really are pretty much at that
level and if you think about you know
well how you know what is it that these
systems have to do to maintain that
level so let me kind of take this
example that I showed you of the 787
Power bus or something like the 787
power bus so what you're seeing here is
across the top are the sources of power
and you see that you have two generators
on the left engine two generators on the
right engine a left auxiliary power unit
or right auxiliary power unit there are
batteries that are in here that are sort
of not shown there are high-voltage AC
buses low voltage AC buses Y for
efficiency right because now you don't
want everything running off high-voltage
AC some things will run more efficiently
off low voltage so you put our buses in
there our high voltage DC low voltage DC
Y for efficiency there transformer units
but look at all the paths between all of
those things right there are lots of
different ways of powering them up and
so what happens in the software that's
running this is that in normal operation
you would say well everything's sort of
functional so I want to use the most
efficient way of routing power and so
you might say okay well I'll power up
right my left and right generators are
running and so I will power up all of
the buses those are the the rectangular
long rectangular things in some way and
so I sort of highlighted the paths of
power that are being used and so
everything should be getting power from
something although I think that the
middle buses they're unpowered somehow
anyway sorry about that and now you say
great so now that's the normal operation
but we know that these generators aren't
going to run for a hundred thousand
years without failing right I mean
you're gonna do maintenance on them
etcetera but at some point when I was
gonna fail and so what do we do when for
example that fails well when that fails
right then the buses that we're getting
supplied by that can no longer supply
power and so we need to reroute that
power so the first thing that happens is
that we lose power on all of those buses
because that was what was getting driven
let's say off of that particular bus and
we need to repower them so the natural
thing you might think of is oh well
that's no problem right you can see
there's buses that are powered up right
next to them let's just connect them all
right now you can't quite do that
because on an aircraft the engines are
not spinning synchronously I mean so in
in the electric power the terrestrial
electric power system all of the
generators are all synchronous they're
all connected together but in an
aircraft those engines are not phased
with each other and so if you connect
them together and that right engine is
still running right and the generator
just isn't quite working right you can
suddenly get to electrical signals that
are connected together out of phase and
that can lead to huge currents and high
temperatures and fires and other things
so you can't do that so you actually
have to disconnect first the buses that
are powering up the old stuff so the
first thing you have to do is disconnect
that and now once they're disconnected
then you can reconnect them via some
other paths and so there's a lot
full sequence of things that have to
happen in a set of constraints on what
that logical sequence can do and the
software has to solve that problem and
that's you got to worry about I just
showed you the right engine failing what
if a different engine fails what if
while the right engine is failing
another engine fails right because if
you're in a bad storm or something so
you can imagine right there all of these
complicated possibilities and that's why
it's so complicated it'll test all of
these things and this of course is
something that as I'm describing it to
you is very much happening in some sense
at a logical level as you can imagine
right you know the sort of tools for
formal methods and verification other
things could be used here but there's
also dynamics that are going on
underneath these things and temporal
constraints right to repower things that
setter etcetera and so it's complicated
and deal 178 C provides ways of doing
that right and in the kind of latest
version it allows for the use of things
like formal methods model-based
development etc to do that having said
all of that it can still be a challenge
and so I'll give you an example of some
of where that challenge can be seen and
this is in a test flight for the 787
basically the system we've been showing
you it's called Z a 0 0 to the the
flight number there is a test flight
this happened back about seven years ago
eight years ago now maybe seven years in
a little bit and on the 787 and so this
is an article and you can see the title
official word from Boeing 787 Dreamliner
fire and smoke details ok that's not
good all right fire and smoke and an
aircraft right you know not what you
want so you know you can't read the text
here so I'll pull out a little bit of it
what it says is that there was a loss of
primary electrical power ok well what
does that mean ok primary electrical
power is the thing that powers the
aircraft right so really what happened
is that the cockpit right lost power
you're looking at a bunch of computer
displays and they go off ok you are now
in a plane flying right this was
actually the plane coming in for a
landing so it's probably a 10 15,000
feet right it's coming in for a landing
and all of a sudden all of the cockpit
displays go off right and all of the
computers that allow right the you know
sticking around on other things to
control something have also gone off
that's what happens when primary
electrical power goes off not good so
first off that should never have
happened right that should be a 1 in all
right you know sort of 10 to the 9th
flight hours thing this is a test flight
right you know sort of what in the world
went on ok so something went wrong and
something didn't happen but engineers
are really careful about things right
and so in fact if you keep reading what
it says is that the ram air turbine the
rat deployed and allowed a safe landing
okay so chances are unless you've heard
me talk before or you're in the
aerospace industry have no idea what a
rat is so the ram air turbine is
something that is underneath virtually
every commercial aircraft um it is
there's a picture pointing to it you can
barely see it down there so let me blow
it up a little bit it looks like this
it's basically mounted up underneath the
fuselage and it's set up so that if you
lose primary electrical power or primary
hydraulic power right then this thing
will automatically drop down into the
airflow there's a prop on the front of
it that starts spinning that prop does
two things it spins up an electric
generator and it spins up hydraulic pump
those go to completely separate circuits
that power up the flight control
computers and the primary flight
actuators right so some engineer
someplace said yeah but what if the
software doesn't work all right the
software doesn't work I want to have a
whole separate redundant circuit right
that's how you get right that
one-in-a-billion
sort of case in there and so that rat
deployed as they're coming in basically
within 30 seconds or something like that
everything comes back up right so they
had to fly kind of open-loop really
open-loop for 30 seconds and then
everything comes back up and then
they've got only what they need to land
the plane right so they land the plane
safely right and you didn't hear about
people dying or other things right
because that safety system came in so
that's an example of the types of things
that our engineers you're doing just to
give you a sense of all of this part of
museum ever heard of these rammer
turbines as they are very rarely used so
they're about a hundred thousand flights
a day globally that means 35 million
flights per year I was able to find six
documented wrapped-up rat deployments
where somebody wrote an article saying
here was a rat deployment right now not
all of them are gonna get published
right so maybe there were ten times that
many right that would be about three per
year on 35 million flights so one in
every 10 million flights right this rat
will deploy I mean how do you verify
that that's right you know sort of do
the right thing in all the right
conditions etc etc so I've actually been
to the the manufacturing floor where
they build these things they actually
have a poster for every time the rat
deployed and they have an um
people whose lives were saved right
because their system deployed because if
their system hadn't deployed that plane
wouldn't have had any power and would
have crashed so that's the type of thing
I think that when you think about safety
critical systems you want to think
that's the sort of mentality you want to
have right you know like no matter what
happens we've got a way to get out of
that thing right so that's the type of
thing that's going on okay so with that
that's sort of you know how aerospace
deals with this thing and a little bit
of the mentality of the things let me
tell you some about where aerospace is
going and you know the types of things
to keep in trying to do so when you look
at the systems that control these so the
control systems the software systems
that control all these systems a fairly
typical scenario will be something like
this and people who are at the boot camp
last week you saw this diagram we've got
some physical system the plane in this
case your autonomous vehicle whatever it
is you have some sensors and actuators
down on that bottom level and then you
have a variety of software loops so at
the next level loop up you have this
sensor processing is probably some
Kalman filters that are doing you know
GPS and other types of things some
feedback controllers keep you in the
lane or keeping you sort of on your
flight path or whatever it is you have
at a higher level some optimization
trajectory optimization other types of
energy optimization optimizing the
sequence of things that are going to get
turned on and off perhaps in that
electric power system and at the highest
level you have some decision-making
logic that might be saying okay we are
in a fault mode or we are you know in
some mode in which we need to discard
some of our goals or other things and so
these multi-layer hierarchies are common
it's very important when you're
designing the system to think about the
environment the environment means the
external things that might affect your
operation and often is a controls person
we think about the environment affecting
just the physical system you know winds
and other things in the content of this
but in fact that environment is really
represented through all of the layers of
the abstraction right because you know
those faults can be things that have an
implication all the way through this is
you're making level but also
increasingly if you think about
something like autonomous vehicles that
external environment is not just your
system and the external things that
might happen to it but the people around
you the other cars around you right now
you know very complicated system and at
the decision-making level do I turn left
or right go through the intersection
said it depends on that environment now
the other thing that's happening is that
increase
these are systems that are networked
system so there's some sort of
networking communication that connects
all these together and that allows a
much more intricate set of interactions
between the different layers of the
abstraction and so we can do things that
are more complicated we can put a lot
more computation on so often these sort
of blocks which are similar to the
blocks I showed you for at the block
diagram for Alice might be things where
we have multiple blocks that are running
at different for solving different
special cases at different sub layers of
abstraction within these layers right
various different things and as we do
that then we have to worry about the
fact that it's a distributed system now
a multiprocessor system so we have
clocks on all of those things they may
not all be synchronized so we might have
events that get seen in different orders
in different places depending on when
they get the message right and so we
have to deal with all of that stuff
another thing that happens is
increasingly the system model that's
sort of at the center is used in the
design stage but increasingly as we
think about online learning and other
things that system is model is something
that gets used at the operational stage
we actually query that model and say if
I turn left what will happen or what's
the maximum speed I can go or other
things so again that complicates the set
of interactions that going on and that
of course as soon as you put a network
on things then people say oh let's talk
to the cloud let's talk to the operators
let's get our other giv subsystems this
is in some sense like just the electric
power system there's a hydraulic system
there's a flight control system there's
a landing gear system right all of that
stuff - and so what to think about you
know how do we manage all of this
complexity and so we can do that of
course in the usual ways that we've
learned from places like computer
science we do it be abstraction so we
can say there are layers of abstraction
and I want to separate those layers so
that some set of engineers are going to
worry about what happens at that lower
physical layer and then another group at
the kind of control layer and another
group at the optimization lea or another
group of the decision-making layer we
often also decompose this when you go
look at teams that are working on this
you'll have the sensors guys over on the
left right and their controls guys right
or the hardware actuator guys over on
the right the optimization people etc
and so these are all ways that we divide
this problem up and I'll tell you that
my own experience has been that that's
where most of the errors occur right is
between these layers that the
assumptions that people make right on
the two sides remember I told you that
was the problem that went wrong in Alice
right when it backed up in the middle
intersection was there was an
inconsistency in the way that two
different teams were thinking about the
problem and so same thing the sensor
guys think one things going on right the
you know optimization guys think of
different things going
and we you know kind of don't get it
right so but nonetheless that's how we
design these systems and one of the ways
that we can kind of try and combat that
is to use contracts I'll see more about
what those are but it assume guarantee
contracts specifically okay so so that's
the type of thing we also have to worry
about not only vertical layers of
abstraction and vertical contracts that
connect sort of the different layers but
also horizontal contracts so now to put
these little arrows in there as we
distribute these systems right then we
have to know how are the other agents
going to behave right if it's a
multi-car system or something like that
okay and so one of the things we've been
doing and trying to you know get the
aerospace industry and increasingly
autonomous car industry use is to get
more formal about use of verification
and synthesis in both model and data
driven simulation and testing okay so
there are lots of systems that this sort
of picture shows up in aerospace systems
is one self-driving cars there's another
factory automation process control looks
something like this smart building smart
grid right smart transportation systems
mobility right and you know things that
we're looking at in this real-time
decision-making program very much look
like them and there are lots of
challenges around all of this so how do
we define the layers and the interfaces
so the vertical contracts how do we
scale to many devices so things I'm an
Internet of Things or mobility systems
that's the horizontal contracts and how
do we keep in mind all of the properties
that we care about stability robustness
security privacy all of those things so
it's a nice rich space in which we can
think about what can be done so I want
to just say a little about
specifications because that's one of the
things that we've been putting a lot of
time on and when you think about the
specification have a bunch of properties
over here on the Left these are things
that you sort of write down and say
these are the properties I'd like to be
true we like to think about breaking
that down into a contract something that
is implementable and has an assumed
guarantee framework we usually write
that in temporal logic or some other
formal mathematical language and that
allows us to then implement things on
the components such that when we compose
when we synthesize something that
satisfies the individual contracts and
we compose them we know it works
correctly together and so that's a way
to think about it and kind of pictorial
you can think about you got some global
property you want to break things up and
that this component should satisfy this
set of sub properties of contract this
one should set these and when I compose
these two things I get a combined
behavior that sits inside my global set
of properties right so somehow the
composition they constrain each other
right so that we're working together
they give you something that works
and if you do that right it gives you
some flexibility because it essentially
gives you modularity that is if I have
component a and I know the component a
satisfies its properties and component B
satisfies this property I know when I
compose them that that subsystem will
satisfy the intersection of those
properties and then the subsystems when
intersected will satisfy that and now
you can go and change component a or
component B as long as you satisfy your
contract right so different companies
can do things in different ways and come
up with new innovations but those
contracts are going to make sure when
you plug it in it works the right way
okay so those are the sorts of things
that we'd like to look at and this
assume guarantee form that is where we
assume that the contracts are under some
assumption on the environment and what
inputs I get I'm going to give you a set
of guarantees on my performance can then
be nested together so you want that for
example if I've got three components
then the guarantees provided by
component two and three should imply the
assumptions that component one is making
and similarly the guarantees from one
and three should imply what if the
assumptions that component two is making
right so that when you put it all
together right the guarantees that one
set provides sit within the assumptions
right that I made in providing my
guarantees right and the circularity all
works so that's the type of thing you'd
like to do okay so and again these
contracts these assume guarantee
contract can be vertical between layers
or they can be horizontal between
elements within the same layer in a
distributed system and so one of the
things we think about is how do you
synthesize these and do other things
okay so once you have contracts then you
can think about how do we check these
contracts and so for the computer
scientists you'll know that model
checking is one way to do that so if I
have here something at just the discrete
layer of abstraction but you can make
similar claims at other levels I might
have some finite state machine that
represents my decision-making logic I
might have some formula here written in
linear temporal logic don't worry if you
don't know that and there are great
tools coming from computer science that
allow us to take the system description
and the property and basically go
through and say yes for all possible
executions of this system the
specifications will be satisfying and so
they will basically formally verify and
what's important here is they will
verify that with different interleavings
on a distributed system right so if one
system operates slightly before the
other clock tick happens or something
like that they check all possible
interleavings very important because in
these distributed systems right that's
where things go wrong but the other
powerful thing they do is that they will
give you a counter example
it doesn't work say no this
specification is not satisfied and
here's a counter example why is that
important because engineers always think
they got it right and they never believe
you and then you go no but think about
this right
what happens if right and then you give
them what happened right in that za zero
zero two flight and they go oh yeah crap
if that happens the entire primary power
system could go down right okay you'd
like to figure that out ahead of time
right rather than by flying and figuring
out the hard way and now that plane was
right you know sort of a
production-ready plane almost right
since flying at final certification I'd
go back and do it so it's really
important that those tools and
techniques work okay so model checkers
are getting much much better they can
check all possible execution traces they
can look at environmental actions so you
get models of what the environment can
do etc if you've not used these then I
would encourage you to learn something
about them there are lots of modern
model checkers that are out there we
tend to use spin and TLC at Caltech they
can handle many many states and the goal
is that we'd like to leverage these
somehow for doing control so this is an
existing technology but I think that the
kind of principles of this technology
have not been realized at all the layers
of abstraction so how do we do that
style of model checking within the
trajectory optimization layer within the
kind of feedback control layer um I
think the other thing we can do is think
about sort of turning around a little
bit and so if we say look I've got a
system model I've got some set of
assumptions the description of the
environment for example I've got some
set of requirements that gives me a
model of what the system environment can
do in some set of formal specifications
and in verification we design some
finite state machine that implements
that decision-making logic and then we
verify that either yes this set of
properties is satisfied for this
environment with this decision-making
logic and so I give you basically a
certificate saying yes you're okay or I
give you a counter example but the other
thing you can do of course is flip this
around and say well geez if I give you
the system model and give you the formal
specifications why not just synthesize
the controller that does that all right
I told you here's what the system is and
here's what I want you to do can't I
write a program that sort of you know
goes and says fine here's the logic for
how to switch on and off right the
electric power system so that you never
short do things together and blah blah
blah blah blah in fact you can do that
and that's called synthesis and you can
do that in
kind of standard computer science
settings that have been known for a
while in control settings there are some
things that make that hard but sort of
doable and so this is sort of where
we've been heading is to do these sorts
of synthesis tools and so I'll just very
briefly tell you about kind of some of
the synthesis tools before I sort of hop
back to autonomous vehicles so we're
interested in what's called reactive
protocol synthesis and so the diagram
might look something like this we're
just at the decision-making layer that
top layer it's all discrete just for
simplicity we've got some process here
that's the process that I'm controlling
the aircraft and I can turn on or off
assert and switches connect certain
buses together right if it's the
electric power system I got some
environment in that environments also
discrete a contactor can fail a sensor
can fail a generator can fail right all
of those would be things that my
environment can do to me and that may
depend on my system state in other words
it may be that you know the contactors
that fail are the ones that are open or
closed or something like that or
anything more likely than something else
and so my environment you can think of
being you know interacting with that and
now the controller process right the
decision-making process gets to look at
right sort of what the current state of
the process is and in this version of
things will allow it to look at what the
current state of the environment is so
we'll assume that that's known or can be
inferred very quickly and then what we'd
like to do is to satisfy some
specification along the lines of what I
wrote down and generally speaking this
is hard to do for general classes of
specifications so in the context of
linear temporal logic a certain class of
specifications it turns out it's doubly
exponentially hard in the size of the
specification so if I have five
specifications all right then it will
take two to the fifth so that's you know
32 times sorry
it'll take 2 to the 2 to the fifth so 2
to the 32nd nanoseconds to do that's a
long time but if I double that I have 10
specifications right it'll take 2 to the
2 to the tenth that's 2 to the 1000
right I work that out that's 10 to the
300 years
right something like that right so
that's like age of the universe right so
right you know that's not going to
happen
so way too complex and that's kind of
stopped us but it turns out that there
is a special class of specifications
called gr one for GM general reactivity
specifications in which we assume
basically this error up here that we can
measure what the environments going to
and that allows us to kind of unwind the
system so I can say the environment
makes a decision based on the current
system state and then my controller gets
to know what the environments going to
do and knows what the process state is
and then makes decision and then we
implement that and then I come back in
the environment so it's like a
Stackelberg game if you do game theory
right you know sort of you're breaking
the symmetry right if you do that it
turns out if you do that that's one and
you look at a special class of
specifications these gr1 specifications
what do they look like in linear
temporal logic they look something like
this so let me not worry too much about
it but they basically say I have a set
of safety assumptions and a set of
progress assumptions so the safety
assumptions are never do the following
thing and the progress assumptions are
always eventually do something over and
over and over again and if I assume that
my environment has safety and progress
assumptions then I should imply that my
system has safety and progress
specifications so if I assume the
environment does something of this form
then I need to guarantee that the system
does something that form that problem
turns out to be much simpler and in fact
it's only cubic in the number of states
that's pretty good right double
exponential Baku Baku begin the number
of states versus a double exponential in
the size of the system specification
it's actually an exponential factor in
there so this is the states to represent
a system spec can be exponential in the
size of the spec but usually aren't and
so it is often the case ain't no
guarantees but that it's a reasonable
number of states and so we've been able
to go and kind of you know pick up these
tools that came out of work by Pinner
Manali and SAR from 2006 and apply them
in many of these control situations so
again gr1 or these general reactivity
formulas and they fit within this
assumed guarantee framework that is I
might use this for the assumptions could
be my higher level of abstraction
assuming something about my lower level
abstraction or my lower level assuming
something about the higher level or it
could be me assuming something about the
environment all of that kind of fits
okay so let me just very quickly kind of
give you an example of how these
synthesis things work we know what why
does this work so I'm going to do this
runner blocker game that Pooh and Wiley
came up with ideas I've got a runner the
runner can either be in this position on
the Left in the top the bottom and the
goal is to get to the right the blocker
can be in one of three positions either
at the top the middle or the bottom and
the idea is that the runner and the
blocker should never be in the same
position so the runner is trying to get
over here and the blocker is
trying to block and of course you can
imagine that if the blocker stays in the
middle forever right
then there's trade of nothing I can do
right because if I move up the blocker
could move up and run into me right and
so what are we going to do about that
setter so we have to assume something
about the blocker we're going to assume
the blocker always has to move and so
now of course what's going to happen if
the blocker moves down I'm going to move
up and then I'm going to get through
I mean if block your moves up I'm gonna
move down and I'm always gonna get
through right so under the assumption
that the block are always moves seems
like there should be a strategy so how
would we find that abstract that
strategy automatically well if we
enumerate all of the possible states so
here was the starting state right and
then what I'm doing is I'm listing all
the possible system states and there are
transitions between those states right
where the red is the blocker making a
move and the blue is the runner making a
move then there's a transition map or a
graph that connects all of these states
together and what I wanted the way to
solve these problems is to say well
let's look at the winning state that's
the thing down here at the bottom these
are losing states we want to never end
up there so let's assume that we started
in the winning state and let's ask the
question from what initial states if the
environment took some action I could
take some actions so that I end up in
that winning state right so that's a
question that you can ask and in this
particular case you would say well if I
start in any one of these two states
there's only one thing that the blocker
can do right move down here and move up
here and when it moves I move over into
the right hand side and I win so now I
can say from any one of these states I'm
winning and now I can ask the question
again from what set of states right if
the environment takes some move I can
find a counter move that always gets me
to goal and of course if you do that you
end up with this and of course now here
what happens is right if the environment
goes this way right then I have two
choices but I'm going to go down so if
the environment moves up I'm gonna move
down I'm not going to right move to the
other spot because then I would run into
the block so now we can just keep
iterating this until we get to a fixed
point until we get no new States and we
can say that's the maximal set of states
from which we can converge we can find a
path down to the winning state and if
that includes my set of initial
conditions right then I win I can win
this problem and we can back out a
strategy from that right seneschal if I
start up here I need to get into the
next set if I start in here and you do
the next net right so you can back out a
strategy so that's how these technique
to work and you can show that that could
be done with cubic complexity okay so we
can apply those types of systems so for
example if we go back to this electric
power system you can write down the
requirements so here's a bunch of them
right no AC bus you'll be simultaneously
powered by more than one AC source right
that was the thing that I told you buses
should be powered according to priority
tables right so maybe you've got you
know certain things are more efficient
than other things not unpowered for more
than 50 milliseconds right so you've got
all these things and the spec that I was
showing you before was implementing
these um and we've got some
environmental descriptions about how
often can things fail right and what
types of things can fail and when we put
all of those together we can essentially
formulate this as a Gron synthesis
problem and formulate the logic that
allows us to well we can first just
write down the specs and you give me a
solution and we can verify that in fact
that works under all possible
interleavings and in fact this can be
done and you can go and show that the
failure that occurred right in the CA 0
0 to flight would be caught then we say
oh yeah what about the sequence of
events but also you can synthesize right
that logic automatically and that
synthesis is particularly useful if your
tuna trying to do design space
exploration what topology should I use
but that de Paulo G depends on whether I
can synthesize a control law right a
decision-making law and I want to do
that automatically right not by hand ok
so now let me just in the last five
minutes come back and talk a little bit
about how might all of this or how do we
think about sort of self-driving cars so
in fact there are a couple of
interesting consumer applications where
I think these ideas can come to play so
one is self-driving cars and I always
like to point out to people people think
of these as new but they're not that new
right in the 1980s our instance was
driving self-driving cars around in
Germany and CMU was doing things right
at the nav lab this is the one of the
early cars the dikmen's had right it's a
big fan with cameras on another thinks
and he was driving it well the team was
driving it on the Autobahn um here in
California but in particularly at
Berkeley and many other places right the
path project was doing autonomy this is
probably down on the 405 freeway or
something and down heading down toward
San Diego where they were doing
platooning and other types of things the
DARPA Grand Challenge I already told you
about right that came around in the
2000s 20 years right after some of this
stuff was already being done um and in
the DARPA Grand Challenge there are a
lot of teams again these are the alumni
who came through and do things and I
already kind of showed you some of the
things that happened there um it was
really only recently that everybody
started getting involved
and so now we're starting to see things
and new techniques are being applied
right so you know exquisite mapping in
the environment is a standard thing that
they do to simplify the problem
lots of machine learning and other
things to classify the obstacle so it
doesn't exist so much back in the early
days much more sophisticated
optimization in control because you
could do more computer so I think the
challenge in this area of course is how
do we go from seven desperate billion
miles to something like zero point zero
seven and are we there yet and you know
can we do it I'll say a little bit more
about that consumer drones are another
interesting one right again drones go
way back right you know sort of about 80
years um the more modern things that we
see things like predator Global Hawk the
military drones are they're the you know
I was on a study that the Air Force
scientific advisory board did where we
believed in the in 2000 that the pilot
was optional for most missions at the
aircraft that the Air Force flies and
things like the DJI phantom so it was a
Shengli was a lung here from Berkeley is
the chairman of the board of DJI and one
of his master students at Hong Kong
University of Science Technology Frank
Wang is the CEO so very much has a
connection back here to Berkeley they
really build on a lot of the advances
and what people are talking about doing
is package delivery swarms personal
transport safety critical stuff all
right because if you're delivering that
you know sort of Amazon package above
the city of Berkeley and that thing
falls out of the sky you got to worry
about what happens so I think they're
interesting things to think about there
and people are starting to put funding
in there it's also interesting to just
look at what that ecosystem looks like
so there are people working on
processors for autonomous vehicles right
so you know all of the Nvidia and others
that you hear about are working on
specialized processors there are people
working on sensors for doing that
cameras laser reading generators radar
etc there are people working on
connectivity because this wants to be
cloud connected and other things there
are people working on the mapping tools
for doing this there are people working
on algorithms to actually implement the
planning and optimization and other
things there are people working on the
security and safety associated with all
of this the development tools for
sociologists and all of this is
happening and then there are people
actually making self-driving cars so
this is what that industry looks like
it's pretty crowded right it's pretty
interesting as an area I think there are
a lot of challenges in how we kind of
deal with all of this and this is
actually a slide that I put up in 2016 I
gave a talk in this room and so I'm
going to put it up again because I think
there's still the right challenges there
are things we've solved and there's
things that are still work to be done um
I
that we basically solve the problem of
driving on city streets with normal
traffic and everybody obeying the rules
that's all condoms cars can do that
today uh I think we have yet to solve
driving and crowded and unstructured
environments where people may or may not
believe you know sort of pay attention
to the rules and so why well because you
have to predict what's going on you have
to understand when you're in a parking
lot what are the rules of the road in a
parking lot
exactly I mean where when you're on a
road that's been blocked and you're
making a u-turn in the middle on purpose
yeah that's right that's most expensive
cars or camera shorts car has right away
automatically you know whether it's the
most expensive or not so right yeah less
expensive just because that's the one
willing to take the damage right um you
know I think the other thing is that
getting accident rates that are on par
with humans right one death in every ten
deaths and every billion miles one death
in every 100 million miles
I think that's doable now the the the
deaths are going to be weirder you're
gonna say why in the world does the
autonomous car do that right but it's
gonna get rid of a lot of the stupid
things that people do like paying
attention your cell phone instead of
what's going on around you mean so well
it'll be different right but I think we
can probably do that the question is is
that good enough
is society going to tolerate that and my
usual argument here is right that if 1%
of the fleet or autonomous cars 1% of
the cars in the US were autonomous cars
so we go forward 5 years right or 3
years and 1% and we're just this safe
right then what does that mean that
means that we're gonna get if it's the
same rate right it was thirty five
thousand deaths right per year in the
u.s. that means we're gonna get 350
deaths per year from autonomous cars
that means every day you're gonna pick
up the San Francisco Chronicle right or
the New York Times or The Washington
Post is gonna say autonomous car kills
child in Michigan right and the next
they're gonna pick it up and say
autonomous car kills you know elderly
person in Florida right and then at on
in the next and you know as a society I
think we're gonna say be an autonomous
cars they are killing people right now
they're not killing people any more
frequently than people are killing
people right but our engineered systems
have to be better so I think we can do
this I just personally don't think it's
gonna be good enough so you can decide
you know what you think but I think
getting 10 to 100x better safety that's
an open problem that's well beyond the
mean time between failure the parts so
for example you have to operate in the
presence
you have to operate with flat tires you
have to operate with engines going out
you have to operate with your sensors
going nuts all of that stuff um I think
that we can do things where 99% of the
miles completed are done in self-driving
mode we see that already that's
different than saying 99% of the trips
are completed right because there's a
lot the hard parts that occur on a trip
right and that's what you care about as
a consumer I get into the autonomous
uber and I get there 99 percent of the
time right I don't care that you know 99
out of 100 miles I mean I probably been
100 miles in Hoover cars right in the
last you know month right and so you
know if every if every month I've got an
uber car that breaks down and then I got
to do something that's a problem right
so you really want 99% of the trips
right because I haven't taken a hundred
trips right I've taken 20
well probably ten trips right okay so
again I think that that's gonna be hard
and in particular with humans I think
using machine learning to improve
performance you know absolutely right
your classification prediction and all
of those things I think using machine
learning to guarantee safety harder
problem not solved I don't know how we
do that one so you know it's really hard
to learn these rare events right one in
every 10 million flights right it's
going to have that rat go down where's
your learning algorithm that's gonna
learn what to do on that type of a
sparse data set it's not a frequent
event right so maybe we have to combine
it with formal methods Oh things all
right last one I think that it's gonna
be relatively easy to have one to two
percent of the car self-driving with
humans as a backup where we allow
accidents to happen at the same rate hmm
so humans as a backup I think the really
challenging parts gonna be when 20 to 80
percent of the cars your shelter ID most
but not all or many but not all right it
actually I think gets easier when a
hundred percent of the cars your
self-driving right because now you can
make assumptions about what the other
cars are going to do that are pretty
common the one to two percent you can
kind of tolerate it and the human
backups there I think the middle is
actually going to be hard so I think
it's you know easier after that but
probably ok so I've gone a little bit
long let me stop there you know I hope I
told you about aerospace systems a
little bit about some of the ways that
people in aerospace think about what's
going on I've told you a little bit
about some of the formalism that people
are using or our groups using and others
are using to try and manage the
complexity of these systems and I said a
little bit about self-driving cars and
you know what needs to be done there in
to really move forward so with that I
will stop and thank you for attention
I'm happy to take questions yeah in the
back yeah no that's a good point so
maybe the way I should rephrase that yep
yeah so so I mean it's you know and
there's no formal basis for it I'm
making it up and just claiming right so
but here's what I would say about it I
think that one of the things economist
cars can do is to say I'm not qualified
to drive in these conditions and I won't
all right so it's snowy outside and I'm
not qualified to drive and so by the way
people are driving in snow right so new
tana me tests in Boston they drive in
snow all the time people drive in rain
people drive in all sorts they drive on
dirt roads right all of that in some
sense you can start layering all those
things in but what I think they will say
is this situation I don't have a map
right or my connectivity has gone down
or too many of my processors have failed
I think they will stop and so that's
part of how we'll get there now we may
not tolerate that as consumers right
because it well you know I get in this
thing and it just says I can't go right
so but you know just even I would say
even when we were doing the DARPA Grand
Challenge my ten years ago I was
convinced at that time that you know we
could drive pretty safely right with
that vehicle at that time right and
again we you know if one of our
processors failed and it mattered we
would simply pull it over to the side of
the road and stop so I think that's you
know just again it's not anything
rigorous now if you want to do more
rigorous you know go look at the
statistics being generated by crews
which is a branch of GM or Google and
others and ask you know what's their
current mean time between dis
engagements right and you know is that
converging toward something that right
would be consistent with my conjecture
sort of so some of them published some
of them don't so in California if you're
testing in California at the least you
have to publish whenever a disengagement
occurs right you have to actually report
that disengagement or an accident occur
sorry and you have to report the number
of disengagement you had another thing
and in particular both Google's sort a
little bit before way mo but way most
some to some extent it used to put out
monthly reports on here sort of our you
know how many miles we drove and how
many dis engagements and other things
and so some of that's available and and
a lot of stuff that gets reported we've
actually gone back in and looked at as
part of some proposals and other things
so some of its available especially here
in California where they have to
disclose more but if you're testing in
Arizona which is why a lot of the
companies are testing there then you
don't have to disclose that so we don't
know as much yeah pretty yep well so I
think okay so first off it's a the the
the two cases are probably different
because of course Tesla is deploying
autopilot where you the consumer or the
safety driver
whereas Cruise is testing with safety
drivers and I you know I think what I
would say is that in the case of Tesla
the point that they point-of-view
they've taken is this is not an
autonomous system right this is a
autopilot right that you were supposed
to pay attention to and then when people
don't pay attention it's the drivers
fault right but I've driven in a Tesla
in autopilot and we drove from San
Francisco Airport to downtown San
Francisco and in my opinion it made two
errors that could have led to an
accident if the driver had not
intervened right in what 15 miles right
so that system is certainly not good
enough to do well I think Cruz and
wham-o & Zuke's and the other companies
that are testing things right there you
know still trying to explore that space
right and push the envelope of what they
can do and sometimes when they push that
envelope right they make mistakes they
learn from those mistakes and other
things so I think they do know what
they're doing but they're trying to
tease out what works and what doesn't
work all right I think I don't think
Cruz I don't people may know better than
I do I don't think anybody has died in
an autonomous vehicle crash
yet with the exception of the Tesla one
where it drove underneath the truck and
we can argue whether that was you know
autonomous or not it was not supposed to
be autonomous they didn't build it that
way
so that's what I would say yeah well
again you know accidents are gonna
happen right so you know the one I like
is they remember what company was but
whoever is doing this in Las Vegas right
the first day they're doing this
autonomous bus in Las Vegas the first
day is like in within an hour of them
starting this service it ran into
something right it ran into a delivery
truck that was backing out right because
it didn't back up in the delivery truck
expected that guy accidents are gonna
happen right and you know in aircraft
shutdowns happen other things happen
right you know the thing doesn't happen
you don't fall out of the sky right but
you know we all get delayed we all have
that you know problem happen so I think
that one wants to decide you know what I
think accidents are okay you want to
minimize those if there's no loss of
life it's a different category right so
fender-benders I think we're still going
to happen yeah that's what the pilot is
there in something
yeah I think it's an interesting
question so so a piece of a that I don't
have that I'd like to collect is if you
look at taxi drivers right so you know
buses are big and people stay other way
etc textures just like any other car
taxis just like any other car in some
sense but you have a chauffeur a person
right whose job it is to do that and
who's only paying attention and doing
all the right stuff and they're trained
to do that
so that would be you know maybe the
epitome of what human driving could be
let's say you know you know comparable
thing I think it'd be interesting to
look at what that is and say is that a
good enough target right because maybe
we can achieve that
I think this other question you asked
about you know are there ways to roll
out so for example I think a problem
that is very doable would be let's I'm
gonna make it really really simple so
let's suppose I say I'm gonna have an
autonomous car and this autonomous car
is gonna run on an exact route and it's
gonna stay in exactly one lane and if
something's in front of it it's gonna
wait until that thing gets out and from
in front of it and then it's gonna drive
through and if the you know somebody
cuts in front of it's gonna stop and it
looks a lot like a train right that is
it's on a track essentially right it's
just that it's not a physical track
right it's just a software track right
and now you know it's just like
longitudinal control right all I got to
do is make sure that I'm not going to
fast forward that I can't stop before
somebody cuts in front of me and that's
a much easier problem all right and I
think there we could probably crank the
rates way high now the question is is
that valuable
all right because that's no better than
a bus except that now if that was an
individual car I don't have to stop at
all the intermediate bus stops to pick
up and drop people off right I can sort
of but now I'm driving instead of a bus
that can hold 30 people I'm driving 30
cars right they can drive individuals so
it's not a very efficient solution so
anyway I do think they're backed off
modes right in which we can get
increased safety and I think looking at
you know and then you know people are
talking about doing things like remotely
right if it comes up on a situation
where I can't move for more than thirty
seconds it phones home right and
somebody comes in sees all the cameras
and says okay here's what you should do
in that situation
lemmie that's the way we do it yeah
I think the biggest challenge is that
this requires getting very formal about
what you're doing at all levels right so
within the aerospace industry when
you're spending a million dollars a seed
and you're spending you know sort of
billions of dollars right developing the
aircraft
you will put years and years and years
into developing the specifications
developing the simulation models
developing the prototyping etc I think
if you're talking about autonomous
vehicles we're not gonna spend a million
dollars per car developing these things
right or a lot billions of dollars to
develop them in million dollars to put
all the safety systems to them so I
think the challenge is how do we take
that point of view and get it to be
applied in a system where the
engineering effort right is going to be
much different and the regulatory
environments going to be much different
and the cost structure is going to be
much different the tools are also not
quite there yet right for situations
like how do I maneuver around people and
bicycles and you know pets and right you
know sort of other cars that's much more
complicated than how do I taxi down the
runway and take off into the sky where
I've got a lot of room around me right
and the only other things around me or
other air vehicles that are following
the same rules right so I think again
how do we reason about the environment
around us I think that's a big problem
how do we once I got some representation
of the environment how to use that
representation to prove in a formal way
that I've got the levels of safety that
whatever society ends up requiring I
think those are a couple okay well with
that thank you
[Applause]